le facebook vous connaissez devrait
changer complètement dans les prochaines
années c'est en tout cas ce qu'a promis
hier son fondateur mark zuckerberg
il annonce que le réseau va miser sur la
confidentialité
tiens tiens tiens on a beaucoup accusé
facebook de vendre nous donner il a dû
se défendent l an dernier de tout ça et
au profit de groupes beaucoup plus fermé
dit il est-ce que c'est faisable
est ce que c'est une bonne nouvelle
mathieu prof s'explique il ya presque un
an marc zuckerberg passer sur le gril
devant les élus du congrès américain
après le scandale cambridge analytica
les données de près de 90 millions
d'usagers avaient été volés pour
influencer la présidentielle américaine
alors la protection de la vie privée qui
était la dernière de ses priorités il y
a huit ans vient soudain de devenir
primordial
qu'est-ce qu'il fait que monsieur
jacques la bac se réveille écoutez il
vient de passer 18 mois absolument
horrible sera bien content car ce mot
mais il n'a pas la cote
une vague d achat
mark zuckerberg veut prendre le virage
vers des conversations en cryptées des
messages éphémère mais qui en théorie
lui offrent moins de données
personnelles
toute l'infrastructure du marché et sur
la circulation marchande des données
personnelles et avec déploiement
anticipé de l'intelligence artificielle
qui se fait justement sur des quantités
massives de données
on voit mal qu'un masque il va aller à
l'encontre de ça il y aurait donc une
contradiction avec le modèle d'affaires
qu'ils ont créé vendre de la publicité
très ciblée avec ces données ce qui
devrait d'ailleurs générer 90 milliards
de dollars cette année
mais ce virage vie privée peut aussi
avoir un effet pernicieux ya déclaration
qui m'inquiète un peu
le métier de jeff y ait ces de traquer
les fausses nouvelles la désinformation
sur internet facebook si ben même nom ne
pourra pas voir ce qui se passe dans des
discussions donc ça être plusieurs pour
nous de détecter les gens qui se disent
ces réseaux la défunt négative mais pour
l'instant il n'y a aucun plan précis
pour amorcer ce virage facebook parle
d'une échéance sur plusieurs années et
encore une fois cela va changer nos vies
chaque fois qu'ils aient facebook
réfection changement ça change le monde
le quart de l'humanité sur facebook mais
ça restera gratuit ce qui veut toujours
dire la même chose qu'à ce service est
gratuit
le produit cvo ici mathieu prost radio
canada montréal